this is the craziest experience because
we're doing this over zoom
you are not in the room with me because
of this virus that i just heard about
your faces with me you know how how
oh that's nice look at that i wrote you
a letter a letter from conan o'brien
yeah writes letters ladies and gentlemen
i wrote you a i wrote you a letter when
your book came out
and went to it man yeah i i wrote you a
letter and you
framed it i framed it but here's the
crazy thing it's covered right
so i'm telling you all my own framing so
check out the edge of it it's really
sweet
with an exacto knife you know
i don't think you can see it but it's
really uneven and horrible
that's how pictures are going to be in
the house from now on
it looks terrible you know it was funny
uh because he didn't think of that
[Laughter]
wouldn't it be pompous if i had sent you
that letter already framed
like my assumption was that it would
mean that much to you and if that's the
way
yes if whenever i sent anybody a letter
because it was coming from me
i sent it framed what if i did that and
that was just my
thing that i did that'd be wonderful
yeah and it was a block of your hair in
it
[Laughter]
exactly